es ist tag 46 im krieg in der ukraine
und jeden tag gibt es neue
horrormeldungen von kriegsverbrechen
einer der wohl ungewollt zum helden im
kampf gegen die russen geworden ist ist
der präsident wollte mir sie lenski am
abend hatte er den britischen premier
boris johnson zu besuch und zusammen
liefen sie durch die noch vor kurzem vor
dem fall stehende hauptstadt kiew ein
schicksal das auch seiner heimatstadt
kleve beschieden war der heimatstadt von
präsident zielinski denn dort sollte der
chef der militärverwaltung die stadt an
die russen übergeben es wäre symbolisch
sicher eine schwere niederlage gewesen
aber der chef der militärverwaltung hat
sich strikt gegen die russischen
eroberer gestemmt und unser reporter
philipp potthoff hat sich mit ihm
getroffen mit alexander will cool
sein job ist die verteidigung der
heimatstadt von ukrainisch helden
präsident sie lenski alexander will
kulas chef der militärverwaltung von
trier ich auch seiner führung ist es zu
verdanken dass die strategisch wichtige
stadt nicht an die russen gefallen ist
bild traf ihn zum interview
friedrich ist das tor zur ukraine
ausrichtung der besetzen region von trey
songz wir stehen in russischen truppen
aus der krim im weg
die besatzer haben versucht mit ihren
flugzeugen auf unserem zivilen flughafen
zu landen es war ein transportflugzeug
und drei kampfjets
aber sofort nach kriegsausbruch hatte
ich angeordnet die landebahn mit
baugeräten zu blockieren dazu war die
gesamte navigation ausgeschaltet die
flugzeuge waren also 200 meter über dem
flughafen die leute die da waren sagten
dass man die piloten erkennen konnte
aber sie konnten nicht lang
danach begann der boden angriff mit
einer kolonne von über 300 fahrzeugen
und panzern versuchten die russen die
stadt zu nehmen doch so lenz gs
heimatstadt hielt stand
es gibt sehr viele ingenieure in der
stadt deshalb konnten innerhalb
kürzester zeit sehr wirksame
verteidigungsanlagen errichten wir haben
die riesige russische armee aus der krim
aufgehalten das waren zehn prozent der
gesamten russischen invasion streitmacht
die russen versuchten sogar will cool
zum aufgeben zu überreden
wie die meisten ukrainischen politiker
erteilte er dem kreml eine klare absage
am zweiten kriegstag hat ein ehemaliger
ukrainische minister der nach der meydan
revolution nach russland geflohen ist
mich kontaktiert er hat gesagt dass wir
irgend einen vertrag mit russland
unterschreiben und mir irgendwelche
privilegien versprochen ich habe ihm
meine meinung sehr deutlich gesagt und
das sofort unseren sicherheitsdiensten
gemeldet
die russische armee ist für will cool
eine horde von faschisten
es gibt ungeheuerliche fälle von
vergewaltigung im dorf krassnitzer wurde
ein 16 jähriges mädchen und eine 78
jährige großmutter vergewaltigt die
russen verhalten sich wie faschisten im
zweiten weltkrieg
[Musik]
ein sieg bedeutet dass die territoriale
integrität der ukraine wieder
hergestellt ist in ihren international
anerkannten grenzen das schließt die
befreiung des dollars und der
ukrainischen krim 1
deswegen ist für den chef der
militärverwaltung von cree wir ich klar
die ukraine muss so lange kämpfen bis
jeder russische soldat das ukrainische
territorium verlassen hat bis die
ukraine gewonnen hat
und nun schalten wir zu unserem reporter
philipp er topfit weshalb ist die
heimatstadt von präsident seelands
kiesow wichtig für die ukraine
ja wie alexander will cool ist schon
gesagt hat diese stadt ist das tor zur
ukraine wenn man aus dem süden kommt die
front ist hier 30 bis 40 kilometer
entfernt und die russischen truppen
versuchen die ganze zeit vorzustoßen das
ist sozusagen die südlichste front des
kessels in die russische armee zu
errichten versucht und wenn die wierig
fällt also wenn sie lance kies
heimatstadt welt dann wird es für die
russen deutlich leichter im kessel vom
süden her zu schließen auf andere große
städte wie die pro beispielsweise
vorzustoßen deshalb muss diese stadt um
jeden preis gehalten werden
boris johnson hat am abend jasinski in
kiew getroffen
genauso wie ursula von der leyen aber
auch andere europäische spitzenpolitiker
die vor ort waren was bedeutet das für
die ukraine
also gerade der besuch von boris johnson
war symbolisch unheimlich wichtig klar
natürlich ist alles symbolpolitik wenn
balls johnston mit no mercy lenski durch
kiew spaziert aber es ist trotzdem
wahnsinnig wichtig das zu zeigen dass
man sich nicht nur in einem rot trifft
im präsidentenpalast von zuletzt gehe
sondern dass sich zwei staats und
regierungschefs treffen durch die
hauptstadt spazieren mit den menschen
sprechen also dass man unheimlich
starkes zeichen von boris johnson zu
sagen ich traue mich hier in eurer
hauptstadt kommen ich traue mich auch zu
hören sind von dieser ganzen von diesem
ganzen sich einfach mit dem präsidenten
durch die hauptstadt zu spazieren mit
ganz normalen bürgern sich zu
unterhalten das ist das wissen die
menschen wahnsinnig zu stellen ja und
auch während der besuche in kiew hat
aber auch immer wieder raketenangriffe
auf den westen gegeben wie sieht es
aktuell dort aus
ja sie der westen des landes da gibt es
immer wieder raketenangriffe aber das
ist nichts im vergleich zu dem was im
osten passiert denn die menschen im
osten bereiten sich auf einen
unglaublich großen russischen angriff
vor womöglich alles in den schatten
stellen könnte was der krieg keine
bislang so gezeigt hat das heißt im
westen rechnen die menschen mit immer
neuen flüchtlingswellen sie schickt
natürlich auch ihre soldaten in den
osten aber dennoch lag in der
westukraine ist deutlich entspannter als
im osten wo man wirklich mit allem
rechnet vielen dank für diese eindrücke
aus lemberg viel pathos